new violence in Sri Lanka less than a
week after suicide bombers killed more
than 250 people a series of explosions
followed by a shootout between Sri
Lanka's military and suspected Islamist
militants erupted overnight more than a
dozen people were killed a military
spokesman says the militants are
believed to be part of the same group
that carried out the Easter Sunday
attacks this as religious leaders urged
the faithful to stay home fearing houses
of worship still remain as targets
Elizabeth Palmer has the latest from Sri
Lanka's capital Colombo Special Forces
first raided a warehouse and discovered
a huge cache of bomb-making equipment
including sticks of dynamite detonator
cable ball bearings and switches they
also found an Isis flag and police
believe this is where the Easter Sunday
bombers may have made the video pledging
allegiance to the Islamic state a second
raid turned into a shootout with
suspected extremists the military says
they detonated three bombs inside a
house
pictures show survivors being treated at
the scene but officials say 15 people
are dead including three women and six
children presumed to be family members
of the extremists almost a week after
the Easter Sunday attacks a new security
camera video shows one of the Bombers on
his way to blow up the Kingsbury hotel
the cruelty of these hotel and church
bombings have traumatized people on this
island and yesterday's raid which
apparently shows extremists had planned
further attacks is bound to amp up
widespread fear for CBS this morning
Saturday I'm Elizabeth Palmer in Colombo
so disturbing